we have a voicemail number which I
invite you to call absolutely any time
of day that number is two one nine to
david p here is a voicemail with a
question about maybe how we might
interpret the current state of a
political affairs take a look yeah hey
Dave I'm gonna mention something when
nobody's mentioned yet I believe the
David or Donald Trump presence
presidency is revenge for electing a
black man as President Barack Obama tell
you what this is why the Republicans are
letting that go I've never heard this
mentioned I believe this is true listen
I have heard it mentioned this idea that
the reason Trump got elected is a racist
response to Barack Obama now what's
really I'm gonna address that in a
second there's a slice of the left that
likes to say Barack Obama's centrism and
failing the middle class is what got
Trump elected there's people on the Left
who like to say that in order to then
say as a result the last thing we need
is Joe Biden because it'll just lead to
another Donald Trump I think that this
is actually an interesting idea that the
caller presents which is that there was
such racist rage about Barack Obama that
there are people who would not maybe
normally have voted for Donald Trump but
did in order to sort of punish the
Democratic Party for electing a black
man I think it exists I don't know that
it's the predominant factor I do think
that there are a lot of race-related
elements including the fear of losing
status as some middle-class white voters
may may have experienced I don't think
that straight-up racism is really
responsible for Donald Trump in the way
racist backlash I guess we call in the
way this caller is referring to mmm but
in a country of 331 million people
there's a little bit of everything right
James Comey
press conference about hillary probably
swung some votes racism in response to
Barack Obama probably swung some votes
Russian social media campaigns swung
some votes you can't say that it's one
thing but it's certainly an interesting
component we have a great bonus show
planned for you today Burger King is
wanting to address climate change by
changing the diets of cows where it gets
its meat what we'll talk about that we
will also talk about a new study which
shows that minimum wage in any US state
does not allow you to afford rent okay
horrifying numbers and I'm actually
going to do it I'm gonna talk a little
bit about cue cue anon cue a nun cannon
as I like to call it sometimes on
today's bonus show get instant access to
the bonus show at join pakman.com
today's bonus show is a good one
otherwise I'll see you tomorrow